we're going to be exploring a number of
aspects to do with Ukraine but let's
begin with John speller to kick us off
thank you thank you chair and I think a
number of the military have have said
that before the start of hostilities
that they think thought that they'd
overestimated in in hindsight they
overestimated the Russian army and
certainly underestimated uh Ukraine and
many commentators fully expected it
wouldn't be possible for Ukraine to
resist what on paper appeared to be an
overwhelming Russian military Advantage
what in your view is the key factors
that have prevented Russia from making
gains over the last year
Asia
so I think one of the main things for me
I mean it's very difficult to single out
one area where Russian poor military
performance has been uh key because it
has been so comprehensive across all
sort of military functions I think
really you know political through to
strategic operation on tactical
objectives have not aligned on the
Russian side at all whereas on the
Ukrainian side they align perfectly the
political objective is to get all
Russians out of Ukraine and that can
translate to military objectives on the
Tactical level so I think that's really
key and then not to go too heavy on
Military Doctrine but in terms of
um fighting Power the conceptual
physical moral components it's been the
moral components so leadership
um ethical foundation and morale which
has really been the difference between
the two sides and that where that is an
area where Ukraine has been in the
ascendancy and Russia is completely
deficient in the moral component of
fighting Power you mentioned the morale
issue one that many
Generals in history of sales as being
the key component of of conflict what's
your assessment now of morale within the
Ukrainian forces and the Russian forces
given that both of them have been taking
significant losses
yes and back to your first question I
think the other thing on the morale
component that it's very difficult to
measure and that is perhaps why there is
an overestimation of Russian
capabilities and underestimation of
Ukrainian uh capabilities uh in terms of
morale I mean from the Russian side as
well they did not start at sort of 100
it's not like a computer game
um a lot of
the force were had been deployed on the
border for you know since April the
previous year and also quite austere
conditions over the winter before they
stepped over the line of departure so
Russian morale was not in a good place
at the very start and then when the you
know the special military operations
sort of three-day operations started to
fail it went further downhill and there
has been nothing apart from sort of
maybe last summer where they've managed
to get some territorial gains in the
East but very slowly at a very high cost
they're really the only
um objectives that they achieve
militarily on the ground which would
raise morale and at the moment I just
can't see anything that is uh realistic
um Russian military objective on the
ground that will do anything to do that
and morale is infectious both if it's
low and high whereas on the Ukrainian
side they have had multiple
um Battlefield successes and morale
stays relatively High across the board
because that that's what they're
prepared to do and also as the fighting
season
starts again you know they again they
are very much in step with their
political
um level of warfare because they know
exactly the job that they need to do and
they have the capabilities to attempt to
do it punching season always gets us
back to Medieval Warfare it doesn't that
doesn't it Andre
yes first of all good morning everyone
thank you for invitation and thank you
for supporting Ukraine or during the
whole this year I'd happy to if you
don't mind I would start with the first
question because it's uh it's something
which we're also studying a lot uh so
what exactly happened and why what does
the underlying reasons for Russian Bad
performance in Ukraine better
performance
um so first of all obviously we can see
that Russians had problems all the way
through throughout the whole
um each each element of the of the
capability they had problems with
Doctrine they had problems with
leadership they had problems with the uh
with the state of their uh
of their weapons and uh and basically
they say oh I mean they have made an
enormous amount of mistakes from the
very beginning particularly uh from the
very beginning when I mean is that they
they started that war with the with the
forces inadequate for the for completion
of the uh of those operational plants
which they had and then when they
started it they uh expected this to be
very easy so the lots of their troops
were moving in a for example as an
example lots of the troops were moving
in a in a sort of logistical transport
mode rather than the assault mode
basically they were they they they they
miscalculated the whole the whole
campaign from the very start question
why that all happened I mean there are
some deep underlying reasons
um you know in in this which
gets us to studying like like the
internal organizational issues within
the Russian Armed Forces which led to
those mistakes because those mistakes
are systemic and to my
um it's sort of hypothesis but but
probably provable that uh we believe
that the key reason is that they don't
have any for years or decades they
didn't have any external control over
their Armed Forces basically no
obviously no Democratic control no
civilian control but no other control
whatsoever so Basic Land forces were
developing as a thing in its own uh
without the any challenging and
basically they uh aren't being
unchallenged for decades they they
basically were rottening from inside and
that what what we believe is there to
stay and that's why we believe that it's
not going to be fixed in a short period
of time uh and that's what why the
commander is returning for example uh
back to the positions uh after they've
been fired as you know probably what I'm
talking about uh and I think that this
is this will be with their Russian army
for some long time that's why I was our
forecast is that they will continue
making lots of mistakes in the future
and generally we'll underperform uh that
that produces morale so uh that produces
low morale because they clearly see that
their their plans are not working uh we
saw lots of their internal letters text
messages uh whatever else they clearly
expected this to be a few day campaign
uh then it didn't work out that severely
hit morale and right now
um as you probably could see the uh any
little progresses which they have are
more attributed to the mercenary groups
rather than them rather than the uh the
regular Armed Forces regular Arm Forces
got stuck and they feel that they
understand that that that essentially
makes morale very very difficult uh for
Ukraine Ukraine expects
counter-offensive Ukraine has been
extremely motivated
um first of all because we don't have
any other chance don't have any Plan B
we need to defend our owns so that gives
a huge motivation of course but also
we've been motivated with the fact that
we were doing better much better than
expected and we we did uh massive
breakthroughs in uh in certain parts of
the front so we know that Russians can
be beaten uh and that we knew from the
very beginning but also reinforced in
during the Autumn counter-offensives so
right now we we know this can be done we
know that exactly how to do that we just
need tools for that and it will be done
so that produces our model thank you
you mentioned the mercenary forces the
Wagner group the history of mercenaries
has been that when things go badly they
tend to fade away why is their morale
holding up
uh they have a very difficult they're
very very different uh culture so to
speak completely so they are most of
them
especially currently are either highly
paid mercenaries which stay away in a
rather relatively safe place and
directing the other groups the main like
assault groups and then they have a lot
of the uh a lot of the people who
basically have a certain attitude to
life and basically for most of them uh
uh they they accepted the the the thing
that that is extremely high chance that
they're not going to survive uh as NATO
just recently NATO intelligence is
recently reported which been reported by
CNN yesterday their losses in Bachmann
for example is five times higher than it
is in Ukrainian which is astonishing
number even for us we we didn't I I
personally was was shocked by that so uh
so that's the uh that's the morale of uh
people who basically not so much holding
uh for anything and uh
um but but but the question is that that
cannot be scaled all the way across the
armed forces and basically scaled on a
on a substantial number so I would look
at this as a monish organization with
the with the uh very different but very
limited uh uh potential okay thank you
very much all right John thank you we've
got two supplementaries on this Kevin
and then Robert
yeah thanks so can I just pick up in
terms of uh the Wagner group and
obviously Edmund comment as well
I mean if you look at for example the
New York Times I think was it yesterday
or today I mean there's quite strong
statements being made by progodian in
terms of suggestion that his groups are
being uh
starved ammunition Etc there clearly is
a lot of politics going on between him
and the chiefs of the general staff for
grasmof and others
what's your thoughts what's actually
going on is it blame culture or is it
what
it's a question to me yes yes sorry okay
um to our opinion uh situation is this
so first of all precaution is extremely
ambitious and very aggressive person
generally and he obviously is attempting
to convert his success into Political
success even limited success
um
and uh basically he is trying to uh to
use that and uh and he obviously is
advertising himself and his group
extremely uh and he's criticizing um
forces uh there is there is a lot of
things to criticize them for because
they are underperforming and they end up
performing in logistics and they depend
on their own forces on supplying of
weapons Etc but we know that there is a
rivalry between the groups and and in
Russia it's a typical Soviet uh story uh
which continues in modern day Russia uh
it's a rivalry between the uh between
the uniform services so they have a
rivalry between FSB and army they have a
rivalry between police and FSB and army
etc etc so obviously there is a rivalry
between the Wagner and uh and the armed
forces and since he is actively pushing
uh agenda of firing some generals
basically interfering in a sort of um
decision-making uh on on particular
generals was extremely aggressive
against some of them so essentially he
tried to interfere in the in the overall
command and as I just said Army is a
thing in its own it's a self-preserving
mechanism in Russia which is extremely
has a closed need and a very tight
culture with decades they found a way to
coexist with one each other and clearly
they don't want anyone from outside to
interfere particularly publicly and so
the rejecting him uh and as by product
they reject the uh his group and and
their and their uh their operations so
yes they are under supplying them uh
unconsciously they don't want them to
scale they don't want them to to grow
bigger than they are that's an internal
internal struggle which we obviously all
look with a great interest at
um I believe that they will continue it
will continue so
perhaps it will damage
damage their results uh but uh I would
like to see perjuring fallen out of
Windows sometime soon I no I won't be
too surprised if that happens okay um
Robert thank you I wanted to ask about
one particular aspect of what uh wooden
Theory have been Russian military
Advantage but doesn't seem to have um
borne fruit which is um Aviation uh so
on the face of it there's a mass of
approximately 10 times uh of Russia over
Ukraine uh and uh to say nothing of an
apparent technological advantage I think
again doesn't seem to have borne fruit
and could I just ask uh both Ed and then
Andre in turn what they feel is this is
the answer to this mystery there clearly
is an aspect of uh Russian uh military
Aviation Doctrine that's lacking of
combined uh control
um but there's also seems to be an
element of it just having been held back
and not deployed so it's a bit of a
mystery because it's one big factor that
you would have thought they would have
used more and I'd like to get to the
bottom of that Ed could I go to Ed first
please yes and in terms of the
superiority of superiority of numbers
you're correct um thing couple of
factors that I'd highlight is that in
Russian military Doctrine I mean and and
practice and culture that land forces
have their sort of priority so in terms
of the command and control land forces
had the priority and they struggled
um especially with communication and
sort of marrying up the land and uh
components
um also made more difficult by
electronic warfare factoricide so
effectively air operations were not
fully integrated with land operations
they don't have a doctrine of combined
air operations and whether we do do we
not in a way that we do know
um and then also I think
there's an element of the weakness in
their targeting cycles and
prioritization as well and how the Air
Force went about the campaign so they
did identify certain targets a lot of
the fixed targets that they
um had to strike I mean you know they
fired the missiles out but they didn't
necessarily do the battlefield damage
assessment so they just assumed well if
we've shot at it it's it's therefore
destroyed which was not certainly the
case and then also a lot of the
um assets that they were to Target were
mobile and the ukrainians knew that they
had to disperse their assets to keep
them alive
um so in the first couple of days of the
operation we saw a lot of air activity
but then that just sort of leveled off
over the last with the first couple of
days and then a wider point on Russian
military which is really dog their
operations is that they don't comp plan
so once plan a had sort of failed
they were not there already with sort of
a plan B plan C fleshed out which NATO
militaries do as a course of
um their planning so effectively when
plan a failed they just didn't back up
and be so just before I go to Andre
could I just press on one point so I
gave you a premise there but I just
which is is it military failure or is it
that they are reserving that uh Air
Force for future operations I think it's
military failure
they're not they're not specifically
trying to preserve their Air Force or
they were they were not at that time
they you know in a war like this you
have to you know take certain
operational losses and
um to achieve your objectives but I
think it was the fact that once they
tried to achieve their objectives in the
last in the first couple of days they
just without a comp plan the Air Force
didn't really know what to do and how to
best support land operations yeah we're
gonna have to make some pros Andre
anything to add quickly to that or uh no
to be honest that gave her extremely
comprehensive answer I I completely
agree I just want to say that uh when
they are not challenged they're using
Air Force in full for example we saw
mariopal which was a city completely
destroyed by the air force uh because
they were safe they were like 20 minutes
basically 10 minutes to fly and nobody
was challenging them there and they just
leveled the city down they would do this
with any other city if they were in
challenge so so it's only about them
being denied okay that opportunity let's
go to some comparances here Sarah do you
want to take us forward
Andre can I just pick upon morale you're
on the ground there what's the morale
and support for the offensive of the
Russian people particularly now partial
mobilization has been put in place in
Russia with significant loss
well I'm based in Ukraine and obviously
we don't uh it's not like I'm on the
ground uh you know understanding exactly
what happens with Russian people but we
do have some some Specialists which are
looking into the Russian Society
along a sort of daily basis I have to
say that these are mixed so um there are
different different parts of the Russian
Society reacting to the war differently
so the most uh sort of intelligent and
let's say Pro was not even Pro Western
but mobile pro-democratic so to speak
part of society they are
um they are shocked obviously and
they've been shocked for a while lots of
them have left
Etc but they're not a decisive Factor uh
they're not making any decisions and
they're not influencing decisions so so
essentially they they've been ignored
and as you know our Russian government
is not restricting anyone to leave to so
they're very welcome to go uh which many
of them did at the same time there is
like um a larger part of the Russian
society which are quite complacent so
some of them support uh the war some of
them don't but they're not like really
into the uh any active movements or any
active even expression of their feelings
and a lot of them are are just accepting
it
it's very difficult to say like about
the proportions because any polls in a
totalitarian state are very extremely uh
they cannot reflect properly the the
situation uh so so we don't believe in
false but polls are certainly showing
that a majority of Russians supporting
uh supporting War suddenly a large part
of them do concerning their
um mobilization as we could see the
mobilization was normally done among the
um
let's say uh uh we with a with us with
the parts of society with less income uh
and they were uh lots of them just
accepted it and very quickly accepted it
and uh we saw people like villagers
basically Gathering and sending their
men to the war without any understanding
what this is for how like what's going
to happen and so on uh then they were
complaining for lack of training and
Equipment but but that didn't change
anything really so we do know that
they're continuing mobilization not that
uh publicly uh but they're still hiring
a recruiting recruiting people
um oh my goodness sort of like a low
level low intensity ongoing basis and at
the moment that doesn't change much in
the society an overall societal like
attitude to the war they're very careful
it seems like not to go to this
situation like it has been a Soviet
Union with Afghanistan which was
extremely unpopular and contributed to
the uh demise of the of the of the
Soviet Union regime and obviously like
anything like World War One when they
had total mobilization and it failed and
the war failed and then the people
returned and Noah
so yeah there's nothing like that at the
moment okay thank you so we're entering
year two relative deadlock
um
how do you compare the capabilities and
warfighting capabilities and the mass
between the two sides Ed
um firstly I mean I think it is an
important point it's year nine um it's
just you know this is the second year of
where
um military operations have
significantly increased and you know the
frontage at the moment is about 1 200
kilometers and that's quite important
just in terms of
understanding sort of the military lay
down and I think back to one of my
previous answers I mean yes numbers are
important and Andre covered sort of the
mobilization on the Russian side and we
understand about the losses that the
Russians and and ukrainians to slightly
lesser extensive
um taking over the first year but this
is all about sustainment and how long
each side can go so it's all about how
you know firstly over the winter that
both sides have recovered for spring
offenses but this also could drag on for
a number of years I agree with Andre's
assessment that there are systemic
issues with the Russian Force
you know if it was one or two issues if
it had been an intelligence failure the
plan had been bad or the operation no
execution of that plan had been bad
there'd be something to sort of focus on
fix but this is just pretty fundamental
um in terms of the Russian side and also
I think Russia has less options we've
seen operational Tempo increase in terms
of the inputs from the Russian side over
the last four weeks but we haven't seen
any operational outputs they are still
making very slow progress in certain
areas which are just not really
that important to the to the wider
campaign and actually I think Russia has
very few options for this potential
Spring offensive not from the Russian
side and I'm actually unconvinced that
they'll be able to achieve that and turn
a military objective into a political
objective we'll come on to the spring
offensive in detail in a bit with Kevin
Kevin Jones I just quickly pick up on
tanks the use and provision of Tanks has
been described as transformative the
numbers are quite low for Ukraine and a
half thousand compared to twelve and a
half thousand ish for Russia so Ukraine
wanted 300 they've got a hundred
um how is this going to change how are
they going to get the tanks there how
when are they going to get the tanks
there how many will actually arrive
there and how will it transform the
battlefield
so on tanks I think you know the first
point is I think the West were quite
slow to provide tanks I think the
decisions that we saw in January should
have been made last October to give them
a time to be integrated and on board and
so they'd be ready for a potential
Spring offensive so in terms of when you
know because each Nation are providing
you know a certain package of Tanks to
add up to just sort of 100 plus so I'm
probably initial trench there might be
more
um Ukraine are going to get them in a
sort of piecemeal fashion and it really
depends how Ukraine wants to use those
tanks I think the 300 number was from
Ukrainian defense planners that would
have been ideal but they you know they
will take which tanks they have you know
there is superiority of Western tanks
over Russian tanks and it depends
whether they want to invest them
straight into the fight now either in
the East or the South or they want to
take you know keep them back and
actually train them collectively at a
higher Echelon to sort of give them that
offensive power later on in the Years
we'll probably explore this in more
detail the tank question Andre do you
have any quick comments before we move
on
I fully agree we've been talking about
tanks for for a long time and the fact
that uh if if something is complex as
tanks are supplied you know in the
winter time for spring it's it's a it's
quite late particularly since an
extremely difficult piece of equipment
with lots of sustainment uh you know
issues to to support it with Etc so yeah
um we we we will certainly do our best
and certainly any any chance to speed up
the delivery would help uh but um uh
comparing to the howitzers like
self-propelled howitzers which we've
been receiving and the other uh pieces
of heavy equipment it indeed comes in a
piece of meal fashion and that's that's
a little bit inconvenient but um yeah
we'll do what we what we have thank you
Sarah we're going to move away now uh
from uh the sort of Russian capabilities
of or thinking prior to the war and look
to the west but before we do that I just
wanted to ask a question about the FSB
and perhaps the hierarchy in which these
agencies the these big Mass groupings uh
operate uh in in Russia we you know you
have these big names uh bortnickoff uh
grasmikov uh
um the uh lavrov peskov all these
characters have worked around uh Putin
for many many years many of them have
somehow connected to the FSB is it right
in saying that he didn't trust the
military to command
The Invasion and therefore replaced some
of the senior personnel with FSB
uh leaders Battalion commanders and so
forth is there any truth in that and
that's one of the reasons why the
initial Invasion stalled because you had
those in command and control were
actually not familiar with the the
military environment
um
um from from our knowledge uh most of
the military planning was still done by
military but that war had to uh had to
have a large pre-military sort of
preparation stage and a very significant
uh element which was related to
um to sort of sabotage operations which
were supposed to support the military
Invasion so basically military were only
involved in a pure like movement of the
troops and the second ground was
supposed to be prepared before that and
that has failed uh as well so
um I I'm not aware of the actual fsback
commanderers actually running the
battalions like military battalions uh
that would be
very unusual because indeed these two
organizations are not collaborating
usually between themselves and they're
not sharing the you know capabilities
Etc uh but uh but it was supposed to be
that they were collaborating it was
supposed to be that one helps each other
and that collaboration didn't work which
is not again it's not surprising us
because they always had rivalry but that
indeed was one of the key uh problems
for Russians from the very beginning of
the campaign
good uh Ed anything sad yes I mean fsp
they certainly from an intelligence part
they sort of LED on the intelligence
preparation of the battlefield ahead and
they did have a probably an outsized uh
role in the planning of the operation
which was then partly handed over to the
military uh I don't think that they were
in necessarily like moving efforts B
into positions of command but Soviets
and then Russian structures also have
sort of FSB embeds sort of widely placed
through throughout the military
um and I think it was partly the
assumptions of the false assumptions
that Putin had about the fact that
Ukraine would you know would not fight
uh in the way that they did which was
partly through the assessment of the
FSB and also I think that started to
change now especially with the fifth
directorate which in the FSB does sort
of foreign interference that they got it
so catastrophically wrong that I think
sort of get that priority order has has
started to change talking of getting it
so catastrophically wrong
Kevin Jones on our committee prior to
the invasion was saying the Russians are
not 10 feet tall I think was the phrase
that you use in other words you know we
should not assume that they're going to
be this uh new modernized Armed Forces
with new doctrines and protocols that's
going to be able to invade in in the way
that perhaps we're all frightened of and
yet the CIA the American president even
was planning made the assumption that
Keith would be overrun offering
president zielinski a helicopter ride
out how was it the case that even
uh Western and Senior Western
intelligence you know sources Services
assume made the assumption that Russell
had this capability which clearly they
didn't well I think in terms of
available data which we knew that the
Russians underperformed in uh Georgia in
2008 and went through a period of
modernization what appears to be the
case is now is that modernization sort
of really did kick off in the first four
years but then when shoyu came in in
2012 it sort of petered out in terms of
the the ambition
um there's a lot of immeasurables like I
said moral components but also Graft in
Russian culture was significant we
assessed it in a certain sort of
percentage it might have been double or
triple that and that had a real issue
the other operations that they had done
in so donbass since 2014 Syria which was
primarily in her campaign and then
supported by lower levels of infantry
and then other operations conducted by
Wagner in Africa they were all much
smaller scale and when Russia does the
large-scale exercises I've had sort of
30 to 50 000 and you know does combine
arms maneuver those exercise is a highly
scripted partly because they also you
know they have to invite NATO
observers so they kind of I think they
believe their own hype in terms of the
system we did as well because it's
actually very difficult to assess how
any military
you know this scale of operation is
unprecedented certainly in the last sort
of I think there was an assumption that
both donbass prior a Crimea and indeed
Syria were almost like the Germans in in
Spain you know prior to the the second
world war is almost like a training
ground for them to explore new uh
capabilities and so just and success is
there and especially in donbassad and
other places LED them to move to the
Battalion tactical group structure which
was wholly inadequate because it's not
how they train so they basically went
and fought with a different structure to
how they trade and that caused a lot of
the issues okay Andre any quick thoughts
yes very quickly I agree uh but also we
from what I've seen uh talking to some
us animal uh during that period of time
is that they mostly concentrated on
their on numbers so like numbers of
planes numbers of Tanks number of people
Etc and basically comparing numbers of
course uh that that would that you know
the Russians had an advantage and also
they did not understand how different uh
Ukrainian and Russian armies began
became over the last 10 years since the
for particularly since 2014 when the war
in donver started Ukrainian Army had
changed dramatically in the approaches
Etc lots of people are considered this
as a more like a soft subject and they
couldn't couldn't couldn't easily be
evaluated so that it didn't feature in
evaluations and um and that that led
them to the wrong conclusions I do
believe that there is now some effort to
understand why those wrong conclusions
have been made
um so we'll we'll see so some big
lessons be like well let's now focus on
who's controlling the agenda the best uh
Emma thanks Jay I'm tree I was just
wondering if we can explore how the
delivery of Western Military Support is
shaped the conflict so far and in
particular how well that's been
coordinated between Ukraine and donor
Nations and particularly interested in
the time frames between when equipment
and support is agreed to when it's
actually then delivered is there a
significant gap between that
um thank you yes so first of all on at
just a general level uh it obviously the
supplies from the West shaped uh
extremely because uh Ukraine was running
out of the ammunition running out of
weapons uh quite soon and so by the by
by by may we already needed a
substantial influx of the
of weapons and as you know they've been
delayed at that time so they started
only arriving June July and became
became actually convert ready in June
and that Gap was the most difficult Gap
in the history of our country so may for
example May in the beginning of June was
the extremely tough uh tough period uh
but luckily then the Western weapons
started to arrive and took the place in
a battlefield and yet they had shown
that they are working very well uh I
spoke to I don't even know how many
soldiers which are actually working on
them personally and in vast majority
they actually like they like them a lot
I mean they're more sort of user
friendly in a way uh they're better
performing they so so so there is a very
positive attitude to what the Allies do
now in terms of logistics of course it's
a huge challenge so we're talking about
tens of different types of uh of similar
weapons if coming from all different
countries all requiring different parts
all requiring different training of the
mechanics sometimes they are coming very
often they come as used
and very often there is a certain lack
of the um of the documentation like how
to support it and so on so of course
these old issues are being resolved but
that's that's provides some additional
challenge to the legislations uh but and
and the and the mechanics supporting
like technical support
um but uh now the the question between
the like a political commitment and
actual physical delivery yes indeed in
certain cases the countries are uh are
kind of slower uh in some cases they're
extremely fast so I've seen for example
the announcements made in one day and
then the actual howitzers arriving in
within a week so uh after the
announcement so so sometimes it's really
fast so it all depends on the country it
all depends on Ministry of Defense it
all depends on the negotiation
everything is handled by Ukraine in a in
a very uh intense personal communication
between emojis ministries of Defense I
know that's like a lot of people are
devoted to that Minister particular
um they're doing I believe a great job
and uh they they the following each of
those of that Supply individually
basically it's like a a little project
each of that and so each project has
different performance different results
and so on yeah thanks Andrew Ed did you
want to add anything to that
just that I think we've seen the
provision
um improve over the year
um you know starting from sort of first
UK host the donor conference which is
then formalized into the Ukraine
um defense contact Group which I think
it's on its eighth iteration which was
on the 20th of January when the tank
provision was one of the most important
uh Parts
um we have seen an improvement there's
still issues that need to be addressed
to look at what Ukraine's future
requirements are I also think it's
highlighted the importance of
standardization of military equipment
across Europe and also defense
industrial capacity which are really
important and then the only other point
is I mean you know you have to also
understand the U.S leadership in this
both in terms of the the amount the
sheer amount that the US have donated
but also in the leadership and sort of
being quite Collective around sort of
Meeting those requirements and
critically also U.S Logistics as in the
neighbor the US were able to move things
from Mainland us into Ukraine faster
than some European nations and although
we do a lot of work and sort of why why
was that
because they invest in it they invest
heavily in their Logistics because they
need to for a variety of reasons and
we're just not up to scratch in that
regard I mean we you know there's a lot
on sort of military Mobility increasing
Logistics But ultimately it's quite
fragmented and very difficult and I hope
that there's a bit of a political driver
to sort of address those issues now
because moving equipment from west to
east very quickly is obviously a key
defense requirement for NATO going
forward
fourth
okay thanks very much indeed um let's
move over to the the air domain um thank
you but there's a lot of like to pick up
there and um perhaps you could just hold
the thoughts later on we're going to
come to uh the uh future and what we
should be doing but you've mentioned
Logistics and the ability of moving
equipment from one place to another and
I've been when we look at our own
capabilities I wonder if you'd comment a
new course about the loss of C-130 and
what that does to their Mobility
capability I'll leave that for the
chairman to come back to you later
though if I may
um for now what I'd just like to pick up
on is the point that you've made about
future Ukrainian requirements now of
course and again you just mentioned that
the provision of Tanks was the last big
ticket request as it were and challenges
seen as on Harvey as having unlocked
leopard too the big ticket request now
of course is for uh Jets and that of
course isn't the response that
something's been responded to In terms
um by the West at the moment although
the course last couple of days the
Americans have got a couple of Ukrainian
Pilots that they're trading on F-16 Sims
out in Tucson is this something you
think is likely to change range and can
it and do we not in any event need to
talk about which Jets
yes and I think you're right that sort
of provision of military technical
assistance to Ukraine has become highly
political
um and also there's obviously a lot of
focus on who might sort of initially
um donate and then sort of to try and
Trigger other donations in kind because
no no country apart from really the US
has the the amount of airframes that
they could provide
um to make a real difference but I think
specifically on air power there's almost
two things I mean there's one which
is support to combat operations say this
year and next year which actually I
think is perhaps less important for
Ukraine at the moment in terms of
directly supporting ground combat
operations from the air but this is an
element of it's a long-term transition
for Ukraine because at some point you
know the shooting will stop in this
phase of the war it might go to a period
of negotiation the shooting might start
again but what is critical is that the
Ukraine can re-establish deterrence over
Russia and then defense and to do that
they're going to need
um you know more modern equipment so I
think back to my previous answer in
terms of sort of current and future as
well I see the air domain sort of more
on those future requirements and
actually I think it would be a useful
opportunity now for NATO similarly how
NATO has sort of Allied command
operations for the current fight and
Allied command transformation sort of
for the future fight that's where we
sort of almost need to divest these
questions and look for long-term support
and I think it's a very sort of boring
programmatic view of those future
requirements of us looking at our own
kit and capabilities across all nations
looking to see when um capabilities are
going offline and starting to sort of
building up their future packages
because that's ultimately what Ukraine
will need going forward yes in the
standardization point you made a moment
ago is the person in there as well as it
did across Ukraine absolutely and I
think again on uh yeah it's less about
the technical specifications of the
aircraft themselves it's all about the
maintenance and you know the maintenance
requirements are going to be more
challenging for Ukraine than the actual
airframes themselves yes although I mean
the reason I was asking that question is
we've heard of course F-16 is the one
that everybody talks about largely
because a lot of them they're relatively
cheap in a relatively cheap and easy in
the scheme of things we of course have
transform typhoons which are really
getting obsolescent air to our only very
long Runway needed long Logistics tale
um we don't hear much said about gripon
which strikes me as being the obvious
aircraft for this theater
yes
um
so my my colleagues who are absolute
power experts mean they have identified
the Gripen as the again from a technical
perspective that would be the one that
is of most value to the ukrainians at
the moment because of the ability for
maintenance
um also to be able to use short runways
which means it can disperse
um which of the rare frames uh cannot at
the moment but like I said I mean I
think we're the you know the battle
currently is that Ukraine would take any
aircraft that we were able to provide
they're not necessarily going to be
picky but back to my point on sort of
the long-term transition I see it as
inevitable so it's good practice to
start the training now and then
obviously when they are potentially
um you know invested or deployed that
that's a separate question so if you're
very keen to point out about the
short-term medium term long term these
are different questions
but again my point is it's almost
inevitable that Ukraine at some point
the future will get these Jets so if
that is the case and you do see it as
inevitable then I think the training is
right to start as early as possible
thank you very much Andre would you
could I hey
yes I agree about technical platforms
and I do agree that we'll be happy to to
work with any platform which comes
earlier because to be honest I mean for
us it's uh it's not a matter of the like
a long long
prospective future we would rather start
like as soon as because for a number of
reasons so first of all they do the Jets
would play a very practical role
even now I mean they would play in a
role particularly with their defense and
uh and uh and and perhaps some other
combined operations so so that we we
have a constant calls from our military
that the Jets are are part of like the
you know much more advanced uh you know
campaign plan and if we have them we
would have a much better chances so uh
so so also at like a separation of the
uh our near plans and then the future
plans shouldn't be like that defined you
know we would rather see this as a
transition from one to the other because
uh first of all uh it's very difficult
to calculate exact end game of this
phase
uh how exactly it's going to end and
whether it's going to end or whether it
will transition into some kind of a
other form of conflict maybe not that
intense and it's difficult to predict uh
because it's still shaping up which is
still forming and it would rather we
would rather influence shaping this up
rather than trying to sit and wait until
until the first phase ends so we can
start to work on another phase also the
complete the the first phase depends on
our Readiness for the for the for the
future uh enduring strengths
particularly if Russians see that we are
preparing for the long game if we are
already setting up such a complex
systems such as petriles for example
which we do already such as fighter jets
and uh so we are we are preparing for
the for the very strong
um you know enduring strengths of
Ukraine in the long term they would
certainly understand that uh they
because right now it's I mean again it's
a hypothesis but it's probably valid one
they want to out avoid the West so they
want to play the resources game in the
terms of that they have more money they
have more people than in Ukraine they
have more equipment and and they and
they expect perhaps the the Western
support will be somehow diminishing or
or exhausting or will run out of the
weapons or ammunition Etc
um we need to prove that different and
we need to we need to build up like
already now for the for the for the
longer future
um so that's I believe it's important
thank you thank you thank you thank you
Robert uh Mark Ed can I start with you
can I make it can I make an analogy with
tanks
so
we're now talking about up to 200
leopards for the Ukraine some various
donor Nations you know if you're going
to form a you know a powerful armored
Brigade
it helps if you've got mainly one tank
but when we gave Challenger 14
challenges that in a sense was as much a
political as a military decision
and after months of agonizing among NATO
Nations and others
when we lent forward and gave the
challenges that politically as it were
broke the dam
so if you use that analogy with aircraft
most of what the ukrainians use are
ex-soviet aircraft that's what they're
trained on and experienced at
maintaining
what they want are more migs for
instance the Polish mig-29s and other
lighter aircraft like f-16s and
potentially Gripen
typhoon if we give that is a more
complex aircraft and more difficult to
maintain but politically
if we were to donate say half a dozen
Thai foods if you make we do actually we
do no we do Kevin Infinity no no this is
going Theory look if we were well I'll
come back to that tomorrow mate
if we come if we were to donate half a
half Squadron of Thai themes politically
to break the Log Jam would they not be
benefit from that even if militarily
they might be difficult to operate
yes um the only sort of caveat to that
that I don't think the provision of
Challenger 2 necessarily broke the dam
on the tanks debate
um that's what the objective was but
actually the German government still
effectively had to Lobby the US to agree
to send m1s at some point in future in
times but we did go first yes we did go
first and I think it's grew pressure on
the Germans but I don't think it
necessarily broke the dam on Fighters I
think yes as a political
um
you know there is value politically in
suggesting that we would um provide
typhoons in whatever numbers to then
have other nations then also contribute
but back to my earlier points I see the
provision of these uh you know typhoon
to Ukraine as is inevitable it just
might not be in the next for example
couple of years so I think there's step
one is to start doing the training so
that it becomes a realistic future
option I mean to you to use a popular
phrase politically you could look at it
as a Sprat to catch a mackerel if you if
you see what it means so Andre what did
Andrew we had president zielinski
address parliament in Westminster Hall
extremely powerfully yeah and he asked
for jets he was very clear he even gave
the speaker you know a kind of fighter
pilot helmet which you may need for
prime minister's questions at some point
but but from a Ukrainian perspective
if the UK could donate some typhoons
does that help you and if so why
yes absolutely will help it's absolutely
definitely uh and clearly uh why because
we indeed there are two parts of that
one military and as soon as we receive
the actually working planes with the
train Pilots with some uh maintenance
training and capability uh certainly we
can deploy them to Frontline and they
can make a massive difference so that's
a military short military answer and
this is a common common opinion of our
military experts
the Air Force
joint command very clear even spoken in
behind the scenes so to speak
um so yeah absolutely politically we we
watched The Challenger and basically a
tank Mass tank story unfolding I I
personally spoken to lots of members of
parliament and politicians and analysts
in in Germany and uh I can say that at
least to their experience uh Challengers
did made a massive uh push for the
Germans to uh to agree on their on on
the attacks that wasn't immediate so
it's not it wasn't automatic uh it was
difficult they still needed to go
through lots of decisions there was
still a lot of pressure but that
pressure uh but but basically challenges
were detrimental for for those decisions
and for that pressure at that point so I
believe that if we draw the analogy from
there I mean I don't know if we can draw
this like in 100 percent but certainly
that worked back then and um and perhaps
it will work with with fighter jets as
well so yeah from our side encouragement
all right thank you uh thank you Mom did
you want to come back and very quickly
please Andre if I make could I just set
aside the political question of what a
typhoon donation would do which I
understand the point that Mark's making
entirely around leveraging other things
but uh you know Andre you're just on the
military use of them I'm just conscious
that we're talking about an aircraft
that requires a very long Runway
um it's highly complex and has a very
long Logistics and contractor tail with
it at the same time and at the end of
that has a very limited air-to-wear only
capability I mean is it that in useful
militarily or will we not be better
looking at what would be more suited
further down the line
I certainly are technically uh what what
we would do is to set up a a joint you
know UK Ukraine working group of
Specialists on this which would look at
particular runways which would look at
particular bases where it can be
serviced and where how it can be uh
serviced and that they would make the
decision I would certainly avoid making
my own statements you know definite from
my perspective yes we can we can work it
out we can work with this but uh
certainly there's like probably
thousands technical questions to be
answered uh before the final final
decision yeah all right thank you for
that we did visit Wharton where they
they put these together and and service
them up in the north west of England
with BAE Systems I did ask how long
would it take to train a MIG fighter to
transfer across to Typhoon and they said
a matter of months so which is which is
quite interesting and therefore if we
had them hypothetically and slid them
across the table probably would be more
political than it would be providing
military assistance my question if I
made it to both is yes absolutely there
is a sense of urgency spring offensive
you want the tanks you want the air
power I think rather than Jets itself
the uh air superiority but you've got a
real mixed bag of haribo's haven't you
with so many platforms on so many levels
and this is long term this is
unsustainable would it not make sense
for Ukraine to absolutely request what's
in the cupboard now but to lock down
what type of tank you want long term
arguably the leopard what type of
aircraft you want in the long term
arguably the F-16 to give Clarity
recognizing that there is political
symbolism which Britain could once again
illustrate were to start across the
typhoons Ed do you want to have a pop at
that first yes and I agree I mean I
think the main thing that you know
drives it is availability of either
vehicles or airframes at the moment and
the issue with availability is it's
never what it is on paper this is
obviously a lot of analysis there you
find that a lot exactly but you know it
makes it a little bit of a challenge
that no one can actually you know pin
down the exact number of these but like
I said my position I mean just partly as
a sort of a side I think also well these
discussions are really important
actually the more immediate needs of
Ukraine is or simpler things like
ammunition and shells Etc so I think we
can get distracted by talking about sort
of more technical capabilities
um but I do see this as something that
long-term Ukraine will get all of these
Jets when they sort of go offline and
sort of back to my earlier answer about
sort of almost splitting this in half to
the immediate fight and then longer term
okay we'll come to we'll come into
detail of what that longer term it might
look like Andre any quick object
of course using single platform for each
or for each type of weapon would be uh
would be much more preferred
standardization is a key uh logistically
it's indeed very difficult so working
with those logisticians almost on a
daily basis and it's uh it's it's indeed
tough but it's workable so it's not like
uh it's not like it it cannot be a um it
cannot be resolved it's just it's just
my it's more difficult question only is
like what is the trade-off between time
and inconvenience so whether the time of
receiving those available items is more
important uh than inconvenience and I
believe that time is more important so I
will and that's why we never complain
about having loads of weapons different
times but we did complain about the
delays okay thank you for that um when
we look at the number of countries that
have actually joined in in sanctions
against Russia it it mounts to only 34
and it's a reminder that there's a
bigger picture taking place here
um I think that leads us in nicely to
the other stakeholders is Richard do you
want to take us forward on this area
or speculation that China is cursing up
to Russia
um maybe with the aim of giving them
weapons
are condemned by both Jen stoltenberg
and the U.S Secretary Anthony blinker
and obviously by us what are the
military and political implications even
six of them shouldn't China provide
military assistance to Russia Ed can I
come to you first
yes I think
in terms of the political uh
consequences I mean it would be a highly
escalatory move and that has sort of
already been communicated
um as you suggested no not just in
relations with the us but also the
relationships
um with Europe at the moment China has
provided a non-lethal systems navigation
tools Etc dual use but they haven't this
far gone for what Russia really needs
which we've already discussed a little
bit about
um it would also potentially invite
sanctions onto the Chinese companies
that would um
potentially supplying those and you know
China does not want that and they
probably do not want the
um the focus I think if they did it
would be a point of no return for China
and also because they gave weapons if
they gave weapons in any sort of you
know for example in a modest
contribution no return in what context
diplomatic politically that they have
sort of gone you know towards siding
with Russia they wouldn't then also not
have any mediation wall that they you
know they on the 24th of February this
year they drafted
um potential which was just sort of
dismissed
um almost immediately but that would not
sort of go and you know what the EU and
us have said in the last sort of week
that that would be a red line that would
be crossed I think the
potential advantages although I they
certainly don't outweigh the cons of
this would that it might have to focus
the US a bit more immediately within
Europe and slightly away from the
indo-pacific but also they they might
need or they might see it as an
opportunity to test some of their their
military equipment for the future and a
lot of their military equipment that
they have developed over the last couple
of years
um have sort of beenverse engineered
from things that they've been provided
by by Russia so there's there's an
element where they need to sort of
perhaps test some of this equipment in a
real operational environment it's a very
good article in The Spectator and I hope
I paraphrased correctly where they were
implying actually what the Germans
introduced a lot in recent months that
China is it could be an opportunity for
China and Russia to change the world
order
by themselves becoming what they would
see is the PowerHouse in the West
and the US in a league two do you think
they'd ever grab this opportunity to try
and
adopt that position because that clearly
is where they always want to be number
one isn't it
but I I think that where that option may
have existed just over a year ago with
the sort of the discussion about a No
Limits friendship I think we now know
that it certainly has limits and I think
the issue with potential support of
military technical assistance to Russia
is there's no guarantee that Russia
would actually be able to use this
equipment to have a decisive effect on
the battlefield I mean they need you
know
um
you one two two one five two millimeter
shells they have a real ammunition
shortage but they also still need the
operational ability to use that
ammunition to to enable maneuver to take
back territory to achieve a political
objective and at the moment it's just
not certain that you know while I think
that military support and again it
depends on the sort of the the volume of
that support but there is no guarantee
that Russia would actually be able to
use that to translate into acceptable
military objectives which there could
then be turned into Political objectives
so there's a lot of risk for China
um you know especially in areas like the
UN China have put a lot of soft power
effort into sort of
um you know certain committees in the UN
Etc sort of you know all of that would
be at risk if they take this step
okay thank you Andre what's what's your
view and I'm assuming that we're trying
to use weapons to be evidence of that on
the battlefield very quickly which you
would pick up and there's no evidence of
that right now I take it
yes so at the moment there is no
evidence uh we would of course pick it
up through various sources even before
it gets to the to the to the to the
battlefield
but certainly when it gets
um of course well we clearly see that
Russian offensives had stalled and
basically they cannot move further and
as we just discussed whatever their
wherever they have a some limited
progress that's even not their regular
Armed Forces so they do run out of
weapons they run out of the um
ammunition they have problems of uh with
the industrial complex so uh in the
resources game which they wanted to play
uh they're not doing that well and for
sure for them the you know opening a
Chinese support would be would be
amazing and uh and and hence very very
dangerous for us uh at the same time
um we highly doubt that uh you know
China really wants Russia to win uh
because indeed if it wins uh it's uh
well first of all it won't win it will
just delay the war for a long long time
and it would make it even more bloody
and if it would make it but but but
Russians are not able they don't have
enough capabilities even if they have an
unlimited amount of weapons even if they
have an unlimited amount of the
ammunition it's still not enough to win
this war and China cannot win it for
them so essentially it's investing in
something which is uh which is extremely
uh damaging for Chinese reputation and
and provide adding no Assurance of any
results whatsoever so uh with the with
the approach which China tries to
demonstrate and project to the global
scene like as a as a sort of a wise and
sort of Peace seeking nation that
certainly doesn't bring them any any
results so
um so that's why that's why it's a big
question mark to be honest I mean it's
too early to say whether they're doing
this or not we'll certainly we'll see if
they do at the moment it's still I
believe in the decision making I want to
give me your presence too to see your
presence due to see the Chinese is he
not he hasn't done it he's due to see
the Chinese is near the president your
president
uh perhaps he has but it's uh yes it
hasn't happened yet it hasn't when is
that due to happen do you know I would I
can't comment on this I I don't know
okay Shannon thanks but uh just to
pursue that a bit further Andre Russia
is uh one of the few friends that China
has if China does lose it would be
significant for Putin it would be
significant for the direction of travel
for Russia and that would be significant
for China so China can't afford Russia
to lose or it would be very very
difficult given where China wants to go
in the world
um and now let's look yeah well I mean
they cannot perhaps for them it would be
on on you know undesirable effect if
Russia collapses uh completely loses
completely except that
except that the you know in this highly
hypothetical scenario it's a question of
how China may see it playing in the case
if Russia is collapsing uh but again we
are talking about a scenario which is um
you know one many and we don't know
exactly uh where we are at this point of
time uh with this scenario but then the
question is like what China can do about
the global isolation of Russia what they
can do about the the fact that it's just
a matter of time when Putin and his team
are convicted criminals in many you know
very difficult crimes like terrorism
like uh you know crimes against humanity
Etc war crimes and so on and uh also
Russia cannot avoid
Canada World economic sanctions and they
cannot avoid the reparations because
they caused an enormous damage to
Ukraine which is again just a matter of
time when these damage got back against
Russia and um and so so so China cannot
save Russia from from its own problems
which they created because because they
went too far I believe that maybe in the
beginning of the war maybe in the first
months it was possible but after cases
such as marupal when they destroyed half
million City completely uh I mean this
certain there's certain you know
Reliance which Rush across but basically
no one can save them right now to be
honest okay but Ed uh India and China
are both
still supporting in one form or another
Russia uh therefore
Russia is hoping for the long game the
purpose of China surely coming in with
its own deal is actually to stall uh any
uh advance that the Ukraine might be
able to make to push Russia Russia back
yes and that brings danger of course
today they're not interested in Russia
losing completely and indeed they are
not supporting the war but they're
certainly not condemning Russia like
like our Western Nations too so
basically uh we are I believe in the
middle of some point where some
decisions will be made by Chinese and
whatever can influence that point of
course it would make sense to do right
now did you want to come in and then to
Derek just I think in terms of support I
mean there's a you know
apart from sort of military overt
military technical assistance to Russia
at this point in time they can do more
on for example technology exchange they
can also do sort of dual news technology
transfer to see that increasing to yeah
to alleviate sort of the sanctions that
Russia has because that that is really a
sort of limiting factor on Russia's
ability to regenerate some some of its
capabilities so they can do that in a
less over way but also I mean I think
from a Chinese point you know keeping
this war going at a certain level might
have advantages because you know if U.S
are diverting the now scarce resources
especially on technical equipment such
as for example high miles ammunition
then they can't go to the useful
distractions exactly thank you very much
let's turn our attention back to closer
to home um Derek
obviously we heard a lot about NATO
Unity uh and the importance of that and
given that everyone now believes this or
most people believe this is going to be
a long drawn-out War uh where would you
sort of one to ten scale where would you
put the level of NATO Unity at this
point in time and do you think it's sort
of it's got the resilience to stick in
there
um so I think Unity has changed slightly
and I I think even without the war in
Ukraine you know this was a pretty
significant last year was a pretty
significant year for NATO anyway with
the fall of cabal towards the end of
2021 and sort of expeditionary
operations not going well for NATO at
all
um the what's happened in the war since
last year is it has enabled NATO to go
back to its Basics and its fundamentals
of defense and deterrence of the
euro-atlantic area and also escalation
management which they have been doing
since the Washington treaty was signed
and it really is NATO's bread and butter
so I think part of the unity is due to
the threat that Russia has posed and
sort of external factors but I also
think it's internal factors because we
were due to have the NATO's new
strategic Concept in 2022 anyway that
said what has happened since the war and
also coalescing around support to
Ukraine is used a very high degree of
NATO Unity both in terms of the
provision of support to Ukraine but also
member states
incurring significant costs you know in
terms of cost of living Etc and you know
price of Commodities and I see what's
critical to that Unity has been U.S
leadership since prior to the invasion
when they shared intelligence suggesting
that Russia was planning a large-scale
invasion of Ukraine and also what they
have done in terms of unlocking all of
the potential political blockers I think
secretary of state blinkerton has done a
very very important job of managing that
and now we're starting to see these
structures that are in slightly
independent of NATO such as the defense
contact Group which I believe has about
52 members so it's not just NATO
so I think you know I'm pretty
optimistic on unity and the other factor
is that the EU and NATO I mean have
signed their third joint declaration
earlier in this year which was laid but
there was far more synergies between
NATO and the EU now than there was
before the War I think they're also
closer to sort of deconflicting their
comparative advantages that we have been
for a long time so actually when you
look more broadly across Europe I don't
think it's just NATO it's sort of all
other issues you know joint
expeditionary Force for example which
again High degree of unity what we're
seeing I think will be sustained but it
is also dependent on what happens on the
ground in Ukraine and be you know
upcoming it's not too far away in our
U.S elections
um in terms of the future in the US
position because you've mentioned quite
right how important the U.S is to all of
this absolutely and that is uh you know
it's a risk and I I imagine it's also a
worry
um for a lot of European nations at the
moment I think we saw in the US with the
you know how Senator McCarthy was
elected as a speaker There Was You Know
reports around then that you support
long-term support to Ukraine was one of
the the issues that they wanted to
discuss so if there was a candidate that
got the presidency in 2024 that was less
sympathetic to Ukraine and you know that
could have a an adverse effect and this
is where I think where NATO is also
looking you're seeing far more
um reports in the language of a sort of
europeanization of NATO as well and a
recognition that really you know
European nations have to step up now
um you know it's not acceptable to
continue to rely
um on U.S security assistance yeah Andre
what's the what's the view for new crane
about
um
originally resilience originally of
course we were
um a little bit surprised with the lack
of involvement of NATO when they're from
the beginning of the war and we
understood that this was
because of the NATO's organization uh
while the NATO countries made a massive
huge enrollment and they helped with
weapons they set up Rammstein format and
so on NATO's as a headquarters
organizations was less involved and um
uh and we we assumed that this was
because they wanted to avoid the
escalation become the sort of considered
as a party to the to the war
um and uh indeed when I spoke to a lot
of government leaders and some of the
analysts who were discussing the
escalation scenarios one of the
escalation scenario was considered that
you know the nature would somehow be
involved and it would be what in U.S in
the Press called The World War III you
know was there multiple multiple
participants from from from different
sides I don't think this this the Putin
isn't at any stage of really threatening
NATO countries now uh he obviously is
barely coping with uh with Ukrainian
front uh I think that this this scenario
is like not that much relevant at the
same time we see a lot of enrollment uh
from some point of time it was um
very significant work been done by NATO
leadership
in terms of the advocacy and in terms of
explaining the war to all different
audiences I think Secretary General is
doing a fantastic job in this because he
he was leading loads of Nations and lots
of uh opinion leaders and societies
through these periods of their you War
fatigue which we had as particular
summertime and then in Autumn and then
and so on so and uh and then NATO became
more involved in different other like
particular aspects so I think that at
the moment that's what we see it's
difficult for us to instrument this is a
ideal version of collaboration or or not
but I think Ukrainian NATO has a has
obviously a common future there is
absolutely no doubt about that we we
certainly
probably would become a very strong
partner for NATO for the for the for the
for the for the nearby future and would
be a very seriously contributing member
to Nato
um in the in the future and I believe
that we need to just to to keep on
collaborating to keep on communicating
and uh and that's uh at the end
partnering and whatever whatever the
different programs I think that's the
way forward so far the framework of the
collabor of the apartment of the support
is established like with Ramstein format
and with other working groups I don't
think it would make sense to change it
uh but um yeah NATO can play obviously a
great part in this okay thank you sure
all right thank you very much indeed
Kevin thanks chair
can I ask what the impact is we've
already touched on it really in terms of
the I think referred ad to the fighting
season but there's clearly a spring
thought coming
um and it's just interesting to know
what
um is going to happen in the conflict in
the coming months in terms of what the
major developments will be can I ask Ed
first then I'll come to
um so I think
in terms of talking about Fighters
seizing fighting seasons and the weather
yes there's an impact of
military equipment such as vehicle
movements and radio batteries Etc they
run down in cold weather Etc but I think
the most important part of this is that
your war is a human activity and it's
fighters on both sides that have been in
pretty terrible conditions on both sides
throughout the war so it's not
necessarily just when the ground enables
maneuvering Vehicles as well but it's
also about preparing the troops again to
sort of get out of pre-prepared
defensive positions and potentially go
on the offensive the current balance on
the ground at the moment is that Russia
currently holds around 17 of Ukrainian
territory up from seven percent which
they had in 2014 and went to a maximum
of around 30 percent towards the end of
March and have lost about 50 percent of
their gains the point there is that the
military balance on the ground suits
neither side we know that Ukraine is
very clear that they want that 17 to be
Zero from a Russian side we're not
entirely sure what they want they wanted
to increase from 17 but also you have to
look at the ground and see what are
those potential military objectives I
think back to the morale point I mean
Ukraine have been pretty
um you know not not necessarily terrible
graphed what they're going to do but
they have options which is the assess
um you know essence of making strategy
and they I think have a very clear idea
of how they need to go about military
operations on the ground I think it's
very much less clear from the Russian
side and also from you know I've seen a
very much a reduction in quality of
Russian soldiers over this mobilization
period we now hesitate to even some of
the footage that I've seen call
um you know Russian Fighters infantry
and some regards for me speaking as an
ex-infanteer I think you need certain
sort of basic infantry skills you know
no movement Without fire pairs fire
maneuver which I just don't see the
Russians doing at the moment so to move
from defensive operations to offensive
operations combined arms maneuver at
scale I'm very skeptical that the
Russians are able to do that
in terms of
see
is the Russians as you say are still
deploying armor without infantry or very
limited infantry is that because them
got it or is it just a
sorry just don't know how to deliver
infantry and armor at the same time
um so I I think it's a bit of both um I
mean the you know there's a 1 200 mile
current front line of around 820 of that
is currently contested
um that's a lot of nature I just don't
think they you know in terms of the
breadth and this is an issue that we've
seen with the Russian operations they
are not coordinated you know in terms of
designating the main effort and making
sure that they have the ammunition and
Logistics support to offensives which
again I just I'm seeing not much
evidence that they are doing that I mean
you know earlier to your question also
in terms of we've got to remember that
it's you know Russian regulars Wagner
and other
um mercenary groups and also militia
units you know unity of command one of
the principles of warfare just does not
exist and the Russians have been really
poor specifically in the east
in the South they were better
um at that so as the time comes and you
know the conditions allow for more
offensive maneuver I'm very skeptical
that the Russians are able to sort of
mass in the quantities needed to make a
breakthrough whereas on the Ukrainian
side I I am pretty optimistic mainly
because of the counter-offensive in
kharkive
um in September last year I mean it was
intelligence-led it was well planned
they probed the line and you know got
lucky where they sort of enabled a break
in the lines and they exploited it very
very quickly they had the confidence as
well to set a limit of exploitation not
get too carried away I mean all of those
points to
um you know operational art which if the
ukrainians have that you know provider
they have the capabilities then I think
they have the advantage ask us in terms
of also in terms of clearly the
a lot of them fightings going on in
donbass and other areas and there's a
indication that around Kershaw and other
other areas other fronts they've
basically built large defensive
positions in terms of the Russians
that is it simplistic to say one's
defensive and the other ones from the
Russian's point of view offensive or
at the moment I mean both sides have
probably you know been both on the
defensive over the winter because it
also allows a period of recuperation and
also specifically to start to stop pile
ammunition and put it to where it's
needed for for when offensive operations
resume where the balance of power is on
the ground at the moment again I mean
you mentioned curse on I mean the
Russians have also shown that they
struggle with River Crossings of smaller
scale water features the ability to go
further west you know west of the NEPA I
think is absolutely off the cards for
the Russians at the moment and also they
they also need to protect the territory
that they currently have I mean one of
their operational objectives was to get
a land bridge from Russia proper to
Crimea which they currently hold at the
moment but they need to hold that
because if that is put under threat the
whole position in Crimea gets under
threat so the I think probably the
defensive in the South they're trying
offensives in the East but for all of
the reasons that I've outlined and they
are effectively misfiring and they just
can't coordinate and designate a main
effort to go forward
hungry
um first of all I agree with uh with
everything Ed said and uh I would just
add that indeed Russians would be trying
to
to make an offensive operation in in the
East uh they planned for it for a long
time uh it didn't work out so far I
don't think they have any political
decision to cancel it completely so I
think that would be still trying
uh we expected it some time ago uh
clearly so that they were not prepared
the capability didn't have that
necessary capability for it and uh
uh but uh but but for them it's a it's a
it's a critical political matter to show
at least some results uh I we commonly
believe that uh the results with the the
sort of a interim goal which they put in
uh in front of themselves would be uh
occupy uh Donetsk uh region completely
which they would call a liberation of
Don bass and would highly advertise it
and so on so that that was their plan
that plan clearly doesn't work out I
don't think it's going to be successful
I think that we have enough forces there
to to make it fail but we haven't seen
any other plan so far so I think that
that would be the only one uh and then
detective theoretically if they are
successful they pledge to go somewhere
else and there were a number of options
but I don't think we will get to that
point now with Ukraine uh it's uh it's
run it's it's rather simpler uh we are
preparing for the counter-offensive uh
we clearly agnostic about the direction
uh because uh this direction will be
determined when the intelligence
on that point of Time Will Tell Us Where
the Russians are less prepared the the
least prepared for the for that
offensive because Crimea sorry
which had described uh was clearly uh an
opportunity based uh plan uh Russia was
completely forgot about Clark if they
they they they sort of didn't include
it's in in the planning they were
concentrating on uh on the east
monsterville then we started the
preparations for the counter-offensive
here soon they started to in some sort
of panic throw the uh forces to him so
on
um and we we uh we started offensive in
Turkey so basically the uh clearly they
don't have officers and they don't have
a high rank officers that don't have a
junior officers of uh enough to hold
that long front line that's that's a
fact so they lost a lot of officers
during this war and they didn't have a
load from the very beginning like
capable officers so so they will not be
able to hold the whole Frontline
um and importantly they also don't have
surgeon core as we all know uh they
still have this NCO uh Doctrine from the
Soviet times which basically uh they're
not they're not having them as an
essential part of the capability
defining part of the capability so
everything is uh the whole burden of
like running troops is on officers
and they don't have enough so I think
that that length of Frontline for them
is completely on
um and then and and unrealistic to hold
and that's why the forecast for them
that they will lose a lot of this in the
springtime and or at least some
substantial part of it
okay I mean thank you uh Richard did you
want to come in on this one just very
quickly uh Andre we hear not often that
the Dunbar says full of precious metals
I mean it's rich in them what I mean
crimea's got the port for the Russians
Don bass economically as I understand it
uh could bear fruit for the Russians
economically in the years ahead
is is that how true is that and what
impact or influence will that have on
the Russians clinging on to that part of
your country
um
it certainly has loads of uh resources
that is true donbass originally was
developed in like centuries agoden but
was always a very scarcely uh sort of
populated area and it was populated
significantly specifically because of
the development of the of Mining and
irons industry so there was originally
donbass was built around that industry
all of it uh so yes uh there are there
are resources and for sure Russians
would try to benefit at the same time uh
it's sad to say but all infrastructure
of donbass oil facilities all industrial
facilities everything is completely
destroyed I mean this war had like uh uh
if you can look you can Google marionca
for example as a as a village which is
literally doesn't exist anymore and this
is and the the pictures were populated
recently online and unfortunately it's
one of many settlements in donbass which
which totally destroyed so I don't think
I don't think they have immediate plans
of sort of benefiting from there from
the from the resources uh they own the
port of mariopal right now temporarily
of course but nevertheless which is
totally destroyed as well the city which
they was almost leveled uh mariopal was
the key port for asovsi for the
transportation of the donbass wars to
the world markets so uh they have access
to resources they have access to
infrastructure except that all
infrastructure is broken
um I I think to be honest I mean the
reason they're clinging to donbass is
because uh they originally had some
medium success there back in 2014 when
they occupied uh half of it and they
developed that whole story about the
donbass people which is artificial in
their information space they developed
this whole story about like Don best
being something very specific and
something which Russians are defending
which obviously is not the case uh and
now they just want to continue that
story because in information space they
are failing because all their constructs
which they were building they're not
holding and that's why they need some
other story to sell and I believe so
that political slash information part of
uh uh is is the key here so far at least
Andre thank you Jim Richard thanks very
much indeed I just want to now step back
and look at the the entire picture as to
where this going we're fond of quoting
Sun Tzu on this uh committee
um he wrote I think two and a half
thousand years ago that the strategy
without tactics is the slowest route to
Victory and that tactics without
strategy is the noise before defeat we
ask successive ministers uh that come in
front of this committee and indeed
military leaders what does Victory look
like indeed what is our mission there
and it slid across to say it's for the
ukrainians
to decide if I was to say that our
mission is to support the people of
Ukraine in liberating all of their
Sovereign territory including Don Basin
Crimea and to help build the long-term
security framework that can stand up to
any Russian aggression in the future
would you agree that that would be a
sound strategy
the question I presume is to me correct
yes absolutely uh we have absolutely
clear plan and that plan involves a
liberation of 100 of our territory and
this is not because we're opportunistic
and it's not because we are vengeful
it's because we are clearly understand
that and life this is done the danger
and the threat will stay with us forever
so we need to why can I ask is Jan
stoltenberg and indeed every other
leader including the United States
President hesitant to join in in
supporting with that clear mission
statement
I believe that because it's difficult
joke and I believe because it's uh it's
tough to calculate upfront and that's
why lots of leaders are careful when
they endorse however we see a lot of
statements about the victory uh and we
do assume that it may come with stages
and we do assume that it's not going to
happen in one day at the same time I
believe that the only hesitation the
only hesitation which any of those
leaders have is that it's a it's a
difficult job militarily because
Russians have still substantial forces
there they still have substantial amount
of weapons including in Crimea and so on
but if we are discouraged by a difficult
difficulty we wouldn't be able to even
start because originally if you remember
a year ago uh the consensus of majority
of the politicians in the west and all
analysts pretty much in the West Was
that Ukraine would go would fail very
quickly which didn't happen so we are
used to work against the woods and we
will we will do this uh we will do this
in the future
um there is no other hesitation except
that military uh toughness of the of
that challenge that that's the only one
okay thank you for that Ed
2023 could therefore be a pivotal year
because if we're saying that is the
mission to liberate the entirety of
Ukraine that requires uh Ukraine to move
very much onto the offensive rather than
defensive punch through the defensive
lines of Russia which is why they've
also tanks requiring our power as well
if they're not seen to gain terrain this
ends up as a frozen conflict so should
this not then provide clarity as to the
urgency for the equipment that we
actually need to give to Ukraine so they
can complete their mission this year
yes I think there is a level of urgency
meaning slightly back to your previous
point I mean I I didn't fully write down
your full mission statement but I think
it's important that the second half of
it it's the long term you know everyone
is who's supporting Ukraine at the
moment in Ukraine fighting
um you know almost a fight for National
survival I mean if we were there not to
provide that long-term support So
Ukraine has the terrorism security
framework to support Ukraine but it's
the future defense what the Terence by
denial to make it basically that no
other Russian leader would attempt what
they have done in say a 5 to 10 15-year
time frame I think that's really
important and yes there's an element of
urgency but also back again to the
secretary General's point that you made
I mean this secretary General's job in
NATO is to build consensus NATO is a
consensus organization that might have
to move slower than we would like but
it's you know if you don't have that
consensus and there are splits earlier
to the point on on Unity I think that's
pretty difficult the other aspect of
this is we do need to manage escalation
and again the that is on the shoulders
of the Secretary General a lot as a main
spokesperson for NATO so I think
managing those two things it's very
difficult to get such a clear
articulation of the mission statement at
this present time we're seeing Russia
actually take an interest not just in
Ukraine but in the Slavic footprint of
Europe
therefore this is doesn't end with
Ukraine this is a a new era of
insecurity where Russia is the aggressor
there's a deficit between our security
envelope and indeed our Democratic map
and that Gap is essentially what Russia
is after so the limitations of what NATO
can do has actually been exposed by
Ukraine one of the first sentences that
came out was
NATO cannot formally get involved it's
not a NATO member
in Ukraine
yes and I think Russia is sort of
seeking to exploit those potential fault
lines but again to an earlier answer
it's not just NATO you know the NATO is
the primary security provider within
Europe and especially it's a coalition
of willing that's really step forward
isn't it that partly and and also
another grouping so you know joint
expeditionary Force has you know its
activity has increased significantly the
you know three leaders meetings uh I
think the first one was the day after
the invasion
um you know the UK Talent Pledge on the
19th were partly by uh Jeff member
states but also Central and Eastern
European you know there's a lot of
political change going on in Europe at
this current time you know Warsaw is
stepping up as one of you know Regional
actor that
um it wouldn't have been considered
prior to this Invasion and also going
with that is you know in increases in
defense spending I think 25 of the
current 30 members of NATO have already
committed to increased defense spending
so there's a lot of changes as well and
within that again going back to the
consensus point that it's very difficult
to manage all of that not just that the
multilateral level but also the
minilateral buy and trilateral level it
goes quite slowly but also I think
probably you know impressively quickly
for an organization such as NATO okay
and just finally Andre NATO clearly is
is where Ukraine wants to end up but as
an interim stage perhaps The Joint
expeditionary force would be that
forward-leaning organization far more
flexible far more engaging without the
limitations that the consensus that
holds back NATO do would you like to see
Ukraine being invited perhaps with
Poland to join the joint expeditionary
Force I would welcome every form of
collaboration with nature so absolutely
we shouldn't be staying away from any
NATO project suggested because uh as far
as we go we can we can contribute to a
lot of NATO programs I'm sure
probably one of the most experienced if
not the most experienced army in the
world at the moment
fighting with the with the very
different conflict which most of NATO
armies had and against a very
sophisticated enemy and so yes we can
contribute to Nato as much as NATO can
contribute to us meanwhile while
politically it's been decided and we
perhaps could also talk about membership
action plan uh even in on the general
terms but while this is happening I
would support any NATO integration any
NATO project personally my question was
specific to the Joint expeditionary
Force absolutely yes okay thank you yes
let's now turn to back to the tactics uh
mark thank you Sharon uh I think Russi
produced an analysis recently on the
first three months of the war
and from memory one of the points it was
a very good report was that they
estimated that Russia in two days fired
off the equivalent of the British Army's
entire artillery ammunition stocks I
don't know how they got that figure but
that was their estimate so
we have lent large amounts of artillery
given large amounts of artery ammunition
to Ukraine
what should the United Kingdom
government and NATO more broadly be
doing to address the shortfalls in web
in our own weapons and ammunition
stockpiles which have been exposed by
the war in Ukraine
yeah and one point I think it's really
important when we talk about military
technical assistance to Ukraine that
it's not sort of you know gifting
donating I see this as an investment and
I think you only have to see from your
Estonian point of view as a Frontline
state that if you look at GDP from
military assistance it comes actually
right up on top so there's there's an
element that we are investing in the
defense of the Atlantic area by support
to Ukraine at the moment
um yes it was a very good reporter and
it shows that ammunition stockpiles
across NATO member states and other
European states are wholly insufficient
for this type of War fighting I think
there's been quite a you know a number
of years of false assumptions made about
what
um industrial fighting at this scale
requires and I think there's two things
at the moment there's you're providing
the ammunition to Ukraine to be able to
achieve its military objectives on the
ground but it's also rebuilding these
stockpiles and apart from the US there's
no one in Europe who is doing
particularly well on this front it's
it's how we go about
um
you know sort of collaborating together
and at the moment it's a bit of a mixed
picture that some
some Nations have effectively gone on
their own put in their orders early as
possible because with supply chain
issues a bit of a legacy from covid that
most of these weapon systems that we're
talking about I mean there's a year to a
year and a half
gap between putting the order in so for
example on on end law so I think we've
seen an element of some Nations going
they're out on their own what we are
seeing with the EU specifically on
ammunition for artillery is that they're
starting to get together and look at
scaling defense industrial capacity
which again no what no one nation has
the ability to do that at this present
time well on that point I mean I mean
some of us I think would argue that in
defense we've we've effectively been
operating you know the 10-year rule of
the 1920s unofficially for several years
but you know maybe that's a that's a
bigger argument for another day but
we've we've certainly not had the war
stocks for any kind of protracted major
war with Russia I think you know even
the chief of the general staff is in
terms acknowledge that
so you talk about industrial capability
we've placed and I'm talking about the
UK now we've placed a small order to
replace some of the in-laws that we've
given to Ukraine but our understanding
as a committee is if you like the
substantive order for thousands of them
has not yet been placed
artillery ammunition
BAE systems are our provider for that
they have not yet been given a major
contract even to replace the ordinary
rounds that we've given to Ukraine let
alone to bolster our war stops from a
couple of days to much longer than that
so in the United Kingdom is this not now
a really pressing necessity because if
you're going to open up new production
lines and start to produce 155
ammunition for instance at scale that
requires investment and time to do it so
aren't you disappointed that so far the
ministry of Defense still hasn't done
that
I am disappointed and I think you know
there needs to be those demand signals
to defense industry to start to scale
production but also this isn't sort of a
peak in demand that might level off as
well this is you know this is moving to
sort of you know proper war production
because on the Russian side that that is
absolutely what their intent is yes
there's been delay in something so for
example end-laws
um there have been other successes so
straight after Nordstrom one and two
incident um you know in order for two
sub-service multi-wall ships that can
protect uh underwater critical National
infrastructure and we are committed to
also protect our allies critical
National infrastructure in their defense
command paper in the high North so it is
a slightly mixed pitcher but I think
where we are in the UK specifically at
the moment is a bit of sort of analysis
paralysis the the process we have
decided to go for is an update to the
integrated review sort of Glo um what I
mean by that is the document Global
Britain in a competitive age where which
is more the international relations side
so to look at your Atlantic security
versus the indo-pacific Tilt and only
once that is complete we then look at
Defense command paper issues and then
perhaps if we're lucky at the same time
defense and security industrial strategy
whereas I believe that we probably had
the data
you know April May last year to
understand you know we need to replenish
the stocks that we I'm sorry to
interpret at the same time because we've
got a very important statement in the
house very shortly so so you
characterized as paralysis by analysis
and I think that's probably right so so
our understanding from industry is
they've been you know they've been asked
for all sorts of quotes
for what they could theoretically do but
no major orders no substantive orders
have been placed so would you agree at
the risk of leading the witness here
would you agree that this is something
that we really must address in the
refresh of the integrated review and in
the associated command paper that we're
going to have to find the money from
somewhere to to massively replenish our
stocks of weapons ammunition artillery
missiles if we're going to have a
credible deterrent effect yes and you
know urgency I mean I I wrote a piece
for the rusi website back in October to
essentially make the point that the
integrated review shouldn't be touched
we should just go straight into a very
programmatic review of the Defense
command paper because we now have data
on how Russia fights which for the last
30 years no European you know whether it
be NATO EU structure it actually
understood exactly how Russians fight
and we obviously overestimated it so I
think we are certainly a couple of
months behind where I think we should be
but also you know this is quite
complicated and I just point to the
example of Germany you know the 100
billion special fund that was set up on
the 27th of February we're still not
actually seeing many orders from that if
at all coming through the system now
there's other procurement issues but
when you're talking to the scale of this
we went to Berkeley if we asked the
question how quickly of the error mod
you're going to spend this money they
said we might spend it over four years
or we might spend it over seven or we
might spend it over ten so as soon as
you say to a bunch of back to a bunch of
politicians we go ah so you mean 10
billion euros a year for 10 years and
when we spoke to the German defense
industry the following day they couldn't
have been more cynical about how quickly
this money was actually going to have
been spent I mean just to get that on
the record and we're tight for time but
but is there anything you want to add on
that from a Ukrainian perspective we
know we're putting this ammunition to
good use but is there anything you want
to add I suggest that we the our key
Partners including UK we have a new in a
policy of industrial collaboration with
Ukraine I think that uh we are in we're
in a situation when we also need to
involve our industry and the industries
of the countries which are bordering
with us I think that we need to bring a
lot of the a lot of the industrial
projects either in in the parts of
Ukraine or uh or close to Ukraine and
there's been some good examples I mean
there's some been good collaborations uh
particularly you may have heard of babco
collaboration with Ukraine but uh it's
just the beginning we need we need to do
more we need to uh for example we can do
many parts at home in Ukraine and save
on Logistics and actually close that
logistic Gap completely we can do some
simple uh relatively simple to start
with some weapons or some some auxiliary
equipment Etc and I think that in this
case we made the bottleneck a lot of the
processes uh but that would require a
new vision and a new sort of
collaboration policy so I would suggest
to do to look at that substantially
thank you very much
thanks very much indeed Dave thanks to
you
um Ed the budget well the upcoming
budget will determine
where defense goes from here with the
allocation to to mod the we've learned a
lot in the United Kingdom support for
Ukraine
um and we've learned how quickly it
stockpiles have gone down and how
capabilities that we thought were at
robust and enduring are actually uh
insufficient and fragile and I wonder
what your assessment is and of course
this doesn't just affect the United
Kingdom this has been an issue for um
Allied Nations but then NATO notably not
including the United States to the same
scale but of course Everything's
Relative they've had
um if you're sending an awful lot more
than everybody else like the United
States says even they're having to
resupply in a hurry from a supply chain
which has atrophied to a greater or
lesser and extent but in purely in terms
of the United Kingdom
shouldn't a shouldn't the Secretary of
State be concerned that we may in fact
be in possession with no disrespect to
men and women in uniform purely in
equipment terms of something akin to an
ornamental Armed Forces insofar as it
certainly looks the part we've got all
the Top Flight equipment we don't have
enough of it we can't resource it in
time of need and when push comes to
shove it proves to be lesser or not
certainly to the same extent providing
the capability that we anticipated it
would is that something that we should
be really concerned about in defense in
the United Kingdom yes I think we should
and sort of highlight the in NATO's uh
strategic concept you know to defend
every inch of Allied territory that is a
substantive change from the previous
Direction and the NATO defense planning
process which is a four-year process
which I believe it's next year which
starts its new cycle will be one of the
drivers for that but specifically with
the UK back to one of my previous points
I think there's an element of you know
there's a cultural element around this
for a long time we have gone for
Exquisite capabilities we've also looked
at
um platforms Etc and then decided to put
additional requirements on and obviously
Ajax is one issue where that has not
gone well what the lessons coming out of
Ukraine has actually shown especially in
terms of other mandarial systems that
you know these don't have to be the best
and you know for example with Poland I
mean they're going
um you know it's the only
um South Korean K2 tank you know from a
tops Trump's perspective it's not as
good as a leopard but you've got a
thousand of them and they're available
now so I think you know there's a
cultural element within the UK that we
need to change and also I think it also
you know you write in terms of
credibility I mean we've been talking
about war fighting division for a long
time a Future Soldier by 2030. you'll go
back to 2015 sdsr which was Joint Force
2025. you know we were supposed to have
a war fighting division ready by 2025
with an a group and a maritime group and
bear in mind the security situation that
looks pretty good about now but the
other thing is it has to be credible and
credibility in the eyes of adversaries
for deterrence but also credible to
allies so could we put a division in the
field now which the baltics have
requested
possibly but is it credible perhaps not
and that's the real issue and that goes
back to Readiness issues which as you
widely highlight you know European and
us as well this is not just an under
investment phase I think it's also that
we have been doing you know
discretionary expeditionary operations
for a long time and that has bent us out
of shape and in terms of those decisions
at least a couple of examples
um is new frigates being fitted for but
not with complex systems and an order
for E7 wedge Tales reduced to three
which some people some professionals
would regard as being so low as to be
pointless isn't is that part of the
Exquisite culture which we have to have
these things but we can't actually fund
we can't actually fund them to do the
job that we require them to do but we
still need to tick the Box
possibly but actually I think the ticks
the Box ticking is more of an issue
within NATO internal processors so NATO
defense planning process favors land
forces and heavy land forces which we
just do not have at the moment but we
have a lot of Exquisite capabilities
which are really important which can be
deployed in areas such as northern
Europe which our allies are really
supportive of us and also capabilities
that we can get together with allies so
for example uh PA America time Patrol
aircraft we have a trilateral with the
US and Norway to basically provide ISR
coverage of that whole area and that's
effectively you know protecting NATO's
one of its flanks and also reinforcement
routes so we make a real
um you know difference and also there
are nuclear deterrence is under NATO
command as well which you know the the
French system is not so I think we we
certainly spend a lot and in these um
you know Exquisite capabilities I think
we could do a bit of a better
messaging and Communications about all
of those things so that we can sort of
marry up that discrepancy by the fact
that you know the one process says I
want a heavy you know Brigade or
Division and we say well we've got an
aircraft carrier you know those two
things don't quite marry up at the
moment
thank you Jim we had two supplementers
Kevin and then Derek
I've got to say and I agree or skeptism
about the ability to deploy a brigade
running in a road isn't it time that
actually what needs to happen especially
with the Army and the mod is that
looking at the new industry we're tag
teaming here we actually try and form
our uh future procure and uh lay down in
terms of particular around to fitting
into that new with your concept rather
than actually keep keep going on saying
that somehow like a virility symbol that
we've got we can uh by division when in
effect we can't we've got five yeah some
of the I think the issue with the the
you know the war fighting division
Sovereign War fighting division as well
that it's become sort of a you know an
aspirational Target that we've also
signaled primarily to the us as well so
not just within a NATO context but also
to our NATO allies so in sort of talking
about it for so long we've sort of got
wrapped up in the fact that that is
exactly what we need lever so you know
that's by 2030 but to provide a you know
uk-led warfighting division with perhaps
a brigade from a joint expeditionary
Force member next year or by 2025 I
would argue is also good enough I think
there's an element where we don't ever
want to sort of acknowledge that we have
to go below the sort of divisional level
and also you know again Future Soldier
with our Brigade combat teams you know
there's a reason we call them the gay
combat teams it's to plug into U.S
constructs as well so there's other
options that we we can go for again if
we sort of slightly change the mindset
about it but a us-led sorry a uk-led
division with other assets from European
nations would obviously be welcomed by
U.S and Europe
Derek so you can just pursue that in one
second
um because I'm not just keep using the
word UK lead and other assets
um
is it your view could we today could the
UK today
um
actually put out
uh UK
fighting division could it could it do
it today
um
perhaps I thought UK led a lot about
otherwise can we do it today
to deploy your UK division UK people
provide a fighting division today a ten
thousand is it ten thousand strong I
think we could get the numbers of
personnel but in order to do that you'd
have to draw from 16 air assault and
also uh three Commando Brigade so it
leaves you with no contingent capability
to do something for example like
operation pitting I think from a
logistics point we would struggle and
also from a vehicle position not just in
terms of armor of a variety
um sorry and also not just tank sorry
armored personnel carriers but also the
logistics support to that we would
struggle again it's The credibility in
the eyes of adversary now I'm sorry to
jump in just would you agree the word
perhaps does not have a very strong
deterrent effect
yeah and that that's my point on cred
that's my point on credibility you put
this into context the reason why the
question is important is because NATO
have increased this the size of its
rapid response force from forty thousand
which we could make a major contribution
you touched on 16 years old Brigade
through Commander Brigade for example up
to 300 000 and we're still pressing you
know the mod for an ancestor what our
contribution would be given that the uh
Secretary General native clearly
believes the threat has increased
therefore response needs to be larger
what would Britain do
so I mean again the the increase of the
NATO response Force I mean again it is
very ambitious and those 300 000 are to
be held at very different levels of
Readiness same as the current native
response force of 40 000 but they're
also more geographically focused so for
example
um you know we currently have estonians
or
um multinational battle group we did
have an uplift of two battle groups
um but we've now withdrawn one which
again I optically I don't don't think
looks good we
um agreed with Germany that we would put
a sort of skeleton Brigade headquarters
in our multinational battle groups to
scale up to that level if required and
the um you know Estonian lithuan you are
happy with that sort of arrangement for
now but I think you're right I mean they
did ask for divisions and we deployed
two battle groups if yes uh just
sticking with armor I think Ed you
talked earlier about your Ambitions and
or frustrations with a failure to
purchase commonality across European
NATO allies I assume Challenger 3 would
fall foul of your ambition for people to
have common or for NATO allies of
commonality for instance that would
presumably be ideally be leopard too
yes in terms of availability so I think
and again this is a personal opinion I
was always in favor of your European
joint procurement again because of the
reasons that we're seeing in terms of
support to Ukraine but also as economic
conditions worsen then the um you know
the benefits of collaboration are you
know significant and I think being back
to my cultural point we we tend to look
at things yes we need Sovereign
capability for a variety of reasons but
we also seem to put a lot of additional
requirements on kitchen equipment which
is poor from a NATO standardization
process I think NATO is now at the level
where they're going to really try and
incentivize not just economically but
also other methods of incentivization to
really try and pool these parts around
certain areas of kids because you know
the interoperability advantages that
they they get are significant and also
beyond the procurement Horizon the
upgrading of that equipment shield and
leopard too across what I don't know a
couple of dozen Nations whereas they're
upgrading an improvement in burden for
Challenger 3 falls on one nation the
United Kingdom yes which well from the
news as well is is currently ahead of
schedule which is okay advantageous we
had one more quick technical question I
think thanks uh I'd want to return to
the point I asked you to consider
earlier about the mobility force and
C-130
um because clearly you made the point
earlier about the ability to move kit
and how important that is at a strategic
and tactical level and the question I'd
just like to ask is a comment on the
mass availability that we have and it
seems to me that if you look at these
heavy tasking of the air not available
yes and I think I mean important to note
as well although the main driver of the
uh refresh of the integrated reviewers
of war in Ukraine there is also the
process started with the fall of Kabul
as well so this the C-130
um you know hopefully is in that
question I mean but it's it's a wider
European issue that apart from the US
the the the
um sorry Europe really lacks strategic
lift and air-to-air refueling
capabilities so if you look at French
and European operations in the cell and
uh bahane and takuba you know the things
that they needed from the us apart from
just ISR and intelligent supports with
strategic lift and air to air refueling
because we can't do it they are really
really expensive and they sort of you
know they're enablers they're not the
really shiny sort of Frontline equipment
but it's something that the Europeans
are now going to have to get around and
say well it's not good enough to have to
rely on the US for all of this because
yes the US you know to reinforce Europe
need all of this but they also have
other priorities around the globe so I
think it would be very foolish just to
rely on U.S capabilities in this regard
okay thank you final question
unconscious there's a statement that
people want to call this one to get to
but if I may end just to conclude
are we really taking this seriously
enough there's great grand statements of
support for Ukraine but it's taken us a
year to get main battle tanks to you
there's still political questions over
air power yet I think we kid ourselves
about us being able to push Russia back
in a a time frame bearing in mind they
do have ability to learn and they do
have an ability to endure hardship far
greater than the west and to test our
patients our commitment as well do you
think the West really is is awake to the
the sense of urgency that is now
required to conclude this before perhaps
Western morale Western uh Collegiate
support starts to to unravel
thank you first of all uh yes the West
took it seriously we received the
equipment and weapons for billions tens
of billions of of uh of in any currency
so yes I mean we that support was
absolutely crucial uh the the only issue
is that we constantly see a lot of
doubts of many from many politicians
about where it goes how the end game
looks like
um you know whether we are lucky going
for for what type of scenario we're
going Etc and those doubts sometimes
self-defer uh politicians from making
some decisions and yes indeed we did the
decisions on tanks decisions and some
other weapons could have been done
earlier that's that's a fact as well and
we believe that we we're currently
delaying the uh some decisions which
would be you know critical so I also the
there's constant discussions of the uh
scenarios of escalations and many of
those are no longer relevant but they're
still deterring the uh deterring the at
least delaying the decisions so I
believe that we could we could we could
be moral result collectively about this
and indeed there's a lot of constant
noise about like some scenarios which
are completely unrealistic for example
when Ukraine is going to negotiate uh
and it happens it storms the brass and
the information space was uh and and I
believe that it confuses the matter
because Putin is clearly not about
negotiations whatsoever he's clearly
after after do whatever he can in order
to destroy Ukraine and uh whatever the
scenario but the resistance is our only
option which we're pursuing so that's uh
that's why we would welcome
um we would welcome further
collaboration further support we believe
we can win absolutely we believe
mathematically we have uh we have very
good chances right now we know how to do
that
if I may remind that in 1940 Churchill
spoke in Neo Parliament and he talked
about Victory without mathematical
chances like we have now we have much
better chances that UK had at that time
and you were resolved completely to win
we resolved absolutely so that's why
let's just let's just do it thank you
all right thank you very much Andre Ed
any final words enough me I think that
was okay summary by Andre Andre thank
you very much indeed for such an
informative session and uh it only goes
to say that our thoughts and prayers are
with all the people of Ukraine during
this very very difficult time not least
what's going to happen the next few
months and we will do our Outlets to
make sure that we can provide all the
necessary support that you require as I
hope we've Illustrated during this
committee session here thank you very
much indeed to you both thank you to my
committee members and to the staff that
brings to this uh this conclusion to the
session order order thank you